über ein echtes Bau Desaster in
Hinterzarten im Schwarzwald berichtete
der Länderspiegel im Dezember 2020 beim
Umbau der Sprungschanze gab es eine böse
Überraschung denn erst bei der Montage
der Stahlelemente für die neuen Anlauf
stellte man fest sie passen gar nicht an
den alten Tor die schöne neue Schanze
hat eine Lücke Fehlplanung Baustopp das
sowas heutzutage so passieren kann ich
ich habe gedacht ich höre nicht richtig
mittlerweile passte Anlauf an den Turm
seit Oktober kann auf der Schanze wieder
gesprungen werden rund 1 Million Euro
hat die Reparatur gekostet allerdings
gibt's nun ein neues Problem der
wasserdichte Beton ist nicht dicht
deshalb läuft Wasser in den neuen
Schaltraum unter der Schanze um die
Ursache zu finden hat die Gemeinde einen
Beweisverfahren eingeleitet
2023 soll es Ergebnisse geben dann wird
entschieden wie es mit der
Dauerbaustelle weitergeht hier kommen
wir bestimmt noch mal vorbei
Anfang Juni berichteten wir aus dem
bayerischen Lonnerstadt über die Tücken
der Energiewende unter dieses Windrad
wollte die Gemeinde eine Solaranlage
bauen das ging aber nicht denn in diesem
Gebiet in dem Windkraft genutzt wird
darf angeblich nicht auch noch eine
Solaranlage stehen das ist ein Stück
weit du bist Deutsch also kennt man ja
die Bürokratie das muss man nicht ganz
nachvollziehen Regina Bruckmann die
Bürgermeisterin von Lonnerstadt wollte
das nicht hinnehmen und kämpfte für die
Solaranlage und siehe da Anfang Oktober
sind die bürokratischen Hürden gefallen
der Freistaat so das zuständige
Wirtschaftsministerium interpretiert das
Gesetz jetzt anders nachdem dann die
Fernsehberichte gelaufen sind im Juni
war es dann wirklich so dass dann eine
Maschinerie in Gang gekommen ist man hat
sich wirklich bemüht dieses Problem zu
lösen ich glaube das Problem war vorher
einfach nicht bekannt dank ihrer
Hartnäckigkeit können Sie ihn Donnerstag
demnächst noch mehr umweltfreundlichen
Strom gewinnen
gewonnen haben sie im hessischen
Egelsbach mit Sicherheit an Erfahrung
denn als der Länderspiegel im Oktober
2021 über diesen neuen Kreisel berichtet
ist der viel zu klein geraten Kosten
125.000 Euro aber die städtischen Busse
kommen nicht rum abenteuerlich
wir Bürger sind nur sprachlos denn der
Bus fährt ja diese Strecke schon seit
vielen Jahren von denen die da was plane
die habe keine Ahnung aber davon jede
Menge seit ein paar Wochen ist der
Baufehler korrigiert der Minikreisel
wurde satt verbreitet jetzt bekommen die
städtischen Busse hier wieder die Kurve
104000 € hat der Umbau unterm Strich
gekostet
Ende Oktober besuchten wir den Gastronom
Bernd Kreis der verzweifelte an der
Sturheit der Bürokratie in der Küche
seiner Weinbar sollte damals längst ein
Koch aus Peru stehen und landestypische
peruanische Gerichte kochen weil das
Restaurant aber kein peruanisches
Ambiente besitze so die Behörden bekam
der Koch kein Visum und dürfte nicht
nach Deutschland
das sitzt irgendjemand hinterm
Schreibtisch hier in Deutschland der
entscheidet über peruanische Kultur wie
das auszusehen hat wahrscheinlich fehlt
ihm der Typ mit der Panflöte als sich
der Länderspiegel einschaltet macht die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit eine Rolle
rückwärts Panflöten und Poncho braucht
nun plötzlich keiner mehr Rafael Montero
bekommt seine Arbeitserlaubnis und darf
nach Deutschland einreisen seit fünf
Wochen steht er nun hier in der Küche
ich bin sehr glücklich hier zu sein
Stuttgart gefällt mir sehr gut mein
größtes Ziel ist es zu arbeiten und
allen Leuten die peruanische Küche näher
zu bringen und ich bin sehr froh dass
ich diese Möglichkeit bekommen habe zu
arbeiten
jetzt sind alle glücklich über dieses
unerwartet tolle Ende dank des ZDF
Länderspiels der sich dessen angenommen
hat sonst wäre nichts passiert wir haben
zufriedene Gäste die können wieder die
peruanischen Spezialitäten genießen
in Stuttgart ist die Geschichte gut
ausgegangen mal schauen welche Hämmer
nächstes Jahr in der
länderspiegelredaktion landen werden bis
zum nächsten mal irgendwo in der
Republik